[Applause]
hey all right what's up what's up what's
up wait okay so wait you were in a band
when you were younger right uh
yeah yeah i mean yeah yeah that kept me
out of trouble right there's garage band
things
this is a bear
you guys were you digging on
and it would come out yeah oh wow yes
would you rather pretend you were uh no
i think i wanted to do uh
to sing look i could always sing but i
couldn't see like the bands that i liked
you know like def leppard like joe
elliott all these kind of guys right
yeah i'm just couldn't do it so
um was it wasn't really my vibe so i
actually didn't really sort of find my
voice until i was later on in life and
just sort of my own sort of styling of
like i was singing a lot of karaoke okay
wait what's your go-to i don't know
because i'm like listening to your deep
tones right now and i'm just curious oh
it's from six six weeks of uh you know
traveling and you know okay i'm
shattered right now i love that that's
that's when i perform janice joplin yeah
exactly yeah yeah well when you're not
shattered what are you seeing at karaoke
you know i i i don't know there's
there's probably
i mean new york state of mind was one of
my faves oh
yeah yeah it's good billy joel yeah um
but yeah it to me is always a great it
was a great thing to do because i had no
money and go sing for free at a karaoke
bar me too thank you too yeah they're
great just be broke
yeah um so is it true that sam rockwell
used to lip sync on stage while you
would hide and you would be the one
singing i would yeah we we did it a few
times yeah
sam has absolutely no singing voice
whatsoever he said before he's a
performer like i think one time i was
hiding behind the curtain i was singing
and he went up and performed it oh my
god and uh yeah but i did that for a lot
of my friends actually they would go you
know get phone numbers and stuff out of
the deal and oh my gosh yeah it was
pretty awesome you're the best wingman
ever
like wow that's amazingly nice you could
have gotten the numbers as long as i'm
saying um wait do you have like a go-to
christmas song since it's like the
season ooh uh you know gosh i mean i
love
all the christmas songs man i love them
i mean i i love the holidays what's the
one if you hear and you're like oh it's
christmas
she's either isn't all christmas songs
that no i mean like the one like i feel
like let us know let us know right
no i feel like until i hear being crosby
seeing white christmas have yourself a
merry little christmas oh okay like
frank sinatra's yeah that kind of stuff
yeah yeah yeah well that's a beautiful
set of memories a lot of versions i'm
just saying always
they're all they all sound like
christmas yeah okay so see i'm more in
particular
frosty this freaking snowman
right it's christmas it depends on the
singer if i get into it there's nothing
to do with the singer it does no it
doesn't a singer can serve a message it
can ruin the christmas song but it's
still a christmas song totally but that
doesn't give me amp if i hear someone
suck on a question that's a different
thing right we'll put you in the
christmas mood right yeah we'll put you
in the christmas mood is a different
thing like yeah it's like uh
i think it's like you know sort of have
yourself a merry little yeah that's a
good one it's beautiful cinnamon a
little cocoa i'm just saying frank's not
just my favorite but whatever yeah yeah
i love eating some fruits yes
do you have any family traditions at
christmas time
um
yeah
they make a lot of babies
they're family
okay they make a lot of babies yeah
there's a lot of people there's a lot of
them
do this one tradition once a year i
don't know when they do it i don't know
how they do it all i know is i have to
buy a lot of gifts
[Music]